how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to cosmic wonder where we
talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the marvel cinematic
universe and today it has
begun our first true leaked video
from the set of spider-man far from home
showing none other than tom holland and
zendaya
themselves in a video that seemingly
confirms something that we were guessing
about spider-man 3 all this time
and this video may even give us more
clues as to
some of the plot at least some of the
romantic plot of spider-man 3.
so we'll jump into it but first be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest spider-man news and so
you can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a tony stark
funko pop provided by heroes hideout.com
check them out for all your funkos and
other awesome marvel merch
so let's play this leaked video and talk
about what we're seeing here
[Music]
[Applause]
now right away it's pretty cool that tom
holland and zendaya
are doing their own stunts now of course
obviously there's bigger stunts that
their stunt doubles do
but it's still cool to see them doing
actual stunts for the film
so the video really isn't that much but
if you do look closely there are some
reveals here
as we go closer we can see that
spider-man is wearing the same
spider-man suit that he was wearing at
the end of spider-man far from home
not a huge surprise there but zendaya is
also wearing the same exact clothes that
she was wearing at the end of spider-man
far from home as well
both were wearing these exact same
outfits in the post-credits scene and
that confirms what we thought since the
ending of spider-man far from home that
spider-man 3 is indeed going to pick up
immediately after the events of
spider-man fire from home
this is confirmed by zendaya's outfit
now it's hard to tell what exactly is
happening here but it seems very
apparent that right after peter parker's
identity is revealed
peter then swings and picks up mj and
the two of them
leave somewhere together now it's hard
to tell what exactly they're on because
what they're actually standing on is
a blue screen frame so they can
literally edit whatever they want to in
this shot but they're most likely
standing on top
of a high building or somewhere similar
that they can kind of take cover from
and from there we can assume since the
romantic interest really started in
spider-man far from home
they'll have a pretty serious talk about
what peter is going to do now
and mj will most likely have some pretty
solid advice compared to what peter is
thinking
now of course peter's first thoughts are
probably going to go to aunt may
however he might not be able to go back
home and visit her so his second thought
will most likely be happy
after all happy just helped him with all
of his endeavors and spider-man fire
from home and is kind of somewhat of a
mentor to him now and he's most likely a
very big part of stark industries right
now he's probably running it next to
pepper
and although it hasn't been confirmed
the actress that played
morgan stark in avengers in game tony
stark and pepper's daughter
is confirmed to be in atlanta right now
and it's widely believed that she is
going to be making an appearance
in spider-man 3. so peter will most
likely go to happy and pepper for some
help
it's not like peter parker isn't
connected after all he was an avenger so
he knows tons of people
including nick fury but since spider-man
3 is supposed to be a multiverse film
who knows what will really happen
now another possibility is that perhaps
somehow mj wants to join peter on this
adventure
after all mj is usually a very big part
of the spider-man story and it was set
up for them to be in a relationship in
spider-man far from home
perhaps mj is going to be a lot more
involved with this than we actually know
as far as what she can do for him well
it's very clear that she's a very
intelligent girl but peter would most
likely need her for the moral support
over anything although i'm sure she's
going to have some pretty good ideas for
him
and it is kind of ironic that she's
swinging with him again since the last
time that they swung together she said
that she never wanted to do it again
but since the world kind of sees
spider-man as a bad guy right now it
makes sense that spider-man would have
to get away quickly so therefore he
probably just swung down
grabbed her and swung away but let me
know what you think about our first
leaked video from the filming of
spider-man 3d with zendaya
and tom holland and let me know what you
think the beginning of spider-man 3 is
going to start out like
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest spider-man 3 news
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for
watching woof
me